شكرًا جزيلاً لك على الانضمام إلينا الآن،
سفيرة الولايات المتحدة السابقة لدى أوكرانيا ماري
إيفانوفيتش، مؤلفة كتاب دروس
من الحافة، مذكرات، وهي الآن في
غلاف ورقي، وكانت لدينا عندما صدرت في
غلاف مقوى، دائمًا في كتاب رائع
موصى به للغاية  موصى به،
فما هو رد فعلك على هذه
التقارير المتفجرة من المنشور الذي
عرض فيه رئيس مجموعة فاغنر أه باغوسيان أه إعطاء أوكرانيا موقع
الرحلات الروسية، هل تعتقد
أنه من الصعب حقًا معرفة جيك، أعني أم
أنك تعرف  فقط عندما تعتقد أنه
لا يمكن أن تتفاجأ بعد الآن بالأشياء
القادمة من روسيا، يمكنك أن
تتفاجأ
ولكن من الواضح أنني أعني أنه كان هناك كان
فيرغسون في الخارج مع أولئك الموجودين
في وزارة الدفاع ولماذا هو
في الخارج معهم  أعني أن
مجموعته من المرتزقة موجودة هناك،
أعني أنني أكره ما يفعلونه لكنهم
هناك يتقاتلون، نعم أعتقد أنهم
عقارب في زجاجة، أعني أنهم
يقاتلون، تعلم أنه من المفترض
أنهم جميعًا على وشك القتال  نفس الجانب ولكنهم
جميعًا يحاولون تطوير أنفسهم
أيضًا في نظر بوتين، صحيح نعم،
وبوتين يلعب ضد الآخر، لذلك
أعتقد أنك تعرف، أعتقد أن
الوضع متوتر للغاية هناك، حيث ضخت روسيا
كميات هائلة من الموارد بشكل واضح  أه
في هذه الحرب والقوى البشرية أم لكنهم ما
زالوا يكافحون أم أن
ضابطين عسكريين روسيين كبار
قُتلوا أمس في شرق أوكرانيا
اعترفت روسيا بذلك على نحو
غير معهود ويأتي ذلك في
اليوم التالي لإغلاق كيث أربع
طائرات عسكرية روسية بالقرب من الحدود
أم ما رأيك  إلى متى
تعتقد أن بوتين قادر على تحمل تكاليف شن
هذه الحرب
بشكل جيد؟ أعتقد أنه كما تعلم أنه
مصمم على الاستمرار، وبالتالي فإن
الثمن من حيث الدماء
والكنز لا يشكل عائقًا بالنسبة له
على الأقل لا.  في هذه المرحلة يمكننا أن
نرى
أم زيلينسكي رئيس
أوكرانيا يقوم بجولة في أوروبا أه
الآن يحاول الحصول على المزيد من الأسلحة الثقيلة
وخاصة بالإضافة إلى
المساعدات المالية وغيرها من المساعدين
لمعركته اليوم وعدت المملكة المتحدة
بالتدريب  الطيارون المقاتلون الأوكرانيون لكنهم
لا يعطونهم
الطائرات الفعلية أم، هل تعتقد أن أوروبا
تفعل ما يكفي لمساعدة أوكرانيا؟
أعتقد أن أوروبا تفعل الكثير تمامًا كما
تفعل الولايات المتحدة المزيد
أم ولكننا بحاجة إلى الاستمرار في العطاء
أوكرانيا بسرعة أكبر وأكثر حتى
تتمكن أوكرانيا من الفوز، أعني أن هذا مهم
لأوكرانيا بشكل واضح بالنسبة
للقضايا الوجودية ولكن من المهم أيضًا بالنسبة
للغرب إذا كنت رئيسًا الآن
سأجعلك رئيسًا الآن
افتراضيًا ماذا ستفعل
لأوكرانيا ذلك  نحن لا نفعل
هذا سؤال جيد حقًا لأنك
تعلم أنني وجهت هذا
الانتقاد ولكن
أعتقد جزئيًا أن ما نراه هو
معجزة لوجستية فيما يتعلق بإيصال
دبابات أبرام إلى ألمانيا هذا الشهر
ثم إلى ألمانيا  فيما يتعلق بأوكرانيا،
أعتقد أن إدارة بايدن
وأوروبا بشكل عام وألمانيا
يقومون بعمل رائع خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع فيما يتعلق بحزمة الثلاثة مليارات دولار،
ولكننا بحاجة إلى القيام بالمزيد والمزيد من
الشيء نفسه والنظر إلى أنظمة أخرى
حسنًا، هل تعلم أنه يجب علينا أن نتبع إجازة المملكة المتحدة
على سبيل المثال بصواريخ طويلة المدى بعيدة المدى، هل
يجب أن نفكر
في المقاتلات المقاتلة وما إلى ذلك،
أعتقد أن هذه كلها أسئلة صحيحة جدًا،
لذا فإن كتابك دروس من الحافة أه
من بين القصص التي يرويها و  إنه يحكي
الكثير ويتحدث عن
كيف أنه عندما كنت أه سفيرًا لدى
أوكرانيا أثناء إدارة ترامب،
تم طردك في النهاية
أه بعد أن رفضت التعهد
بالولاء لترامب أه، تكتب عن ذلك
في الكتاب أريد الحصول على رد فعلك
على التعليقات  ما قاله السيد ترامب بشأن
أوكرانيا الأسبوع الماضي في قاعة سي إن إن
إذا كنت رئيسًا، فسأقوم بتسوية تلك الحرب
في يوم واحد، 24 ساعة،
سأسوي تلك الحرب في يوم واحد بالطبع
سألتقي ببوتين، سألتقي
بزيلينسكي  كلاهما لديه نقاط ضعف
وكلاهما لديه نقاط قوة وفي غضون 24
ساعة ستنتهي الحرب، ستنتهي
بالتأكيد، هل تريد أن
تفوز أوكرانيا بهذه الحرب؟ لا أعتقد أنه من حيث
الفوز والخسارة الآن
رد زيلينسكي على  مع الإشارة إلى أنه من
الواضح أن روسيا كانت في حالة حرب مع أوكرانيا
طوال السنوات الأربع التي كان فيها ترامب
رئيسًا، لم يستولوا على
البلد بأكمله، بل استولوا فقط على
بعض المنطقة الواقعة إلى الشرق بالإضافة
إلى شبه جزيرة القرم
ولكن ماذا تفعل؟  كيف يمكنك أن تأخذ
تصريحاته
جيدًا؟ أعتقد أن ترامب هو ترامب آه، كما
تعلم حيث يُدلي بتصريحات
ليست بالضرورة مرتبطة بالواقع،
نعم، قال أيضًا في وقت ما
أنه وآه بوتين تحدثا عن آه
بوتين يغزو أوكرانيا و و  اه هل
تعرف أي شيء عن ذلك لا أنا لا أعرف
أي شيء عن ذلك نعم من يدري إذا كان
صحيحًا أم لا أود أن أعرف المزيد
أه السفيرة السابقة ماري إيفانوفيتش
مؤلفة الكتاب العظيم دروس من
الحافة مذكرات صدرت الآن أه  في
غلاف ورقي شكرا جزيلا لكونك
هنا يسعدني رؤيتك شكرا